Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Alici.
Ich bin heute so ständiger als für Sie.
Ich würde gerne jetzt mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja, kurz zum Ablaufen.
Ich würde so als ein paar Fragen Ihre persönliche Daten stellen.
Danach direkt so Ihre allgemeine, über Ihre allgemeine Bechwörter gehen.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Frank Petersen.
Frank?
Ja, Petersen. Wie Peter?
Peter.
S-E-N. Peter-Send.
Petersen, ja.
Ja, Herr Petersen. Wie alt sind Sie denn?
53.
Wann sind Sie ganz genau geboren?
Am 4. Februar 1970.
Könnten Sie mir Ihre schwer beraten?
Wie viel Wegen Sie so seit?
73 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 Meter.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Ja, Herr Petersen, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so seit circa 10 Stunden ganz starke Bauchschmerzen.
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt, so starke Bauchschmerzen.
Sonst noch was, außer Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe erbrochen.
Einige Male, glaube ich, 3-mal erbrochen.
Ja, es geht mir nicht gut.
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich kann mich nicht groß bewegen.
Ich muss immer eher liegen.
Ich kann auch nicht gut sitzen.
Das tut so weh im Bauch.
Gut.
Ja, Herr Petersen, seit wann haben Sie diese unangenehme Bauchschmerzen?
Seit circa 10 Stunden.
Wo sind die Schmerzen ganz genau?
Eigentlich tut es überall im Bauch weh.
Ganz im Bauch, ja.
Im ganzen Bauch, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr im Oberbauch.
Aber eigentlich überall im Bauch.
Okay.
Herr Petersen, sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen wieder weg?
Ja, die sind dauerhaft da, sie sind so dumpf.
Manchmal auch so eine Welle.
Aber sie sind immer da.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Von 1 bis 10 Uhr bei 1 sehr leichter Schmerzen
und 10 unerträglicher Schmerzen entspricht.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einschätzen?
8 bis 9.
So stark.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen bis Ende dieser Gespräche aushalten
oder muss ich dagegen etwas tun?
Wenn es nicht zu lange dauert mit dem Gespräch?
Nein, nicht so lange, ja.
Um ca. 15 Minuten.
Das geht, das kann ich auch sagen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen auch gefallen?
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich kann mir das schon nicht erklären.
Ich habe diese Schmerzen, so ähnliche Bauchschmerzen,
habe ich schon mal gehabt, in der letzten 2 Jahre,
3 mal ca. aber nicht so stark.
Sind die Schmerzen ähnliche oder?
Ähnlich, aber nicht so stark.
Wie viel mal haben Sie innerhalb dieser 2 Jahren?
3 Mal.
2 Jahre.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Gibt es etwas...
Also...
dass diese Schmerzen windert oder verstärkt?
Windert.
Ja, also jetzt kann ich nicht gut gehen.
Ich muss mich nicht bewegen, das tut noch mehr weh.
Das wäre schon nervant, ja.
Dann immer aufs Sofa gelegt und die Knie etwas angezogen,
aber so richtig geholfen hat das alles nicht.
Ich habe auch mal Schmerztabletten jetzt genommen,
vor 3 Stunden, Parazithaumol, 2 Stück,
aber das hat auch nichts geholfen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Petersen, sind die Schmerzen in einem anderen Körperregion...
strahlend die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus?
Also so ein bisschen auch im Rücken.
Ich glaube, da strahlt das etwas aus in den Rücken,
aber sonst nicht.
Also sind die Schmerzen vom Ausgang,
ein anderen Ort?
Hauptsächlich im Bauch, im Oberbauch,
aber im gesamten Bauch auch, aber hauptsächlich im Oberbauch.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Herr Petersen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay, so fällig Sie haben sie nicht gemessen?
Nein, nicht gemessen, aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl.
Okay, da haben Sie Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß?
Ja, ich habe heute Nacht stark geschwitzt.
Das habe ich, aber Schüttelfrost nicht, aber ich habe stark geschwitzt.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Petersen, wie ist die Rapetit?
Der ist jetzt, seitdem ich diese Schmerzen habe, eigentlich ganz schlecht.
Ich habe nichts gegessen in den letzten Stunden.
Okay, Sie haben drei Mal gebrochen, ne?
Ja.
Und Sie haben auch gleichzeitig Übel.
Okay.
Haben Sie den auch gefällt, dass Sie in der letzter Zeit etwas ab- oder zugenommen,
hat sich gewisch verändert?
Ja, also mein Gewicht hat sich schon verändert,
so auch in den letzten zwei Jahren, wo ich dann auch schon mal diese Bauchschmerzen hatte,
da habe ich jetzt acht Kilo abgenommen.
In zwei Jahren, ne?
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Weißerlössern oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, Wasserlasten habe ich jetzt in den letzten Stunden wenig,
weil ich habe so stark geschwitzt und aber auch wenig getrunken, glaube ich.
Ein letzter Stuhlgang war ungefähr vor,
also nicht einem Tag, 24 Stunden, da habe ich aber keine Probleme mit.
Das war normal, ja.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen waschwindel oder schwarz vor den Augen
oder haben Sie das bewusst sein verloren?
Nein, das ist nicht das.
Okay.
Herr Petersen, ich möchte über Ihre Vorerkrankung-Geschichte etwas wissen.
Ja.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche wichtige Erkrankungen oder chronische Krankheiten haben Sie?
Also ich habe so seit fünf Jahren habe ich erhöhten Blutbrug,
da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein und dann habe ich noch etwas zu hohes Cholesterin.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Bluthochdruck, ich meine.
Nehm ich Dietüde Haar, heißt das, Dietüde Haar, nehme ich eine Tablette morgens
und ich nehme Ramie-Priel 5, eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Also, wie schreibt man Dietüde Haar?
Dietüde Haar, ich habe hier ein Zettel, da steht D, Y, T, I, D, E, Dietüde
und dahinter ein großes Haar, das ist auch ein Mittel, das den Blutdruck beeinflussen soll.
Leicht, ja.
Und Ramie-Priel, wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
5 Milligramm.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen, Hypercholesterin?
Was ist Hypercholesterin, Amy?
Also, Sie haben gesagt, dass die Blutverzwarte zu...
Achso, Cholesterin, Hypercholesterin.
Ich nehme das Mittel, heißt Rosovastatin, Rosovastatin, 20, die Trinke, eine Abends.
Und sonst noch was, außer die beiden?
Ich habe vor einem Jahr, habe ich ein Herzkatheter gehabt, weil ich hatte Herzrhythmusstörungen,
das unregelmäßig und dann wurde ein Katheter gemacht und da wurde, das glaube ich,
mit Kälte behandelt und seitdem ist das der Herzrhythmus in Ordnung.
Gut. Das war vor einem Jahr, ne?
Das war vor einem Jahr.
Okay. Also, nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein, außer die drei?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Gegen diese Schmerzen, zwei Mal, Paracetamol habe ich eingenommen, aber ohne das hat aber nicht geholfen.
Herr Pettersen, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind am Leistenbruch, auf der rechten Seite, da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
Und dann hatte ich mal einen komplizierten Bruch an der linken Hand.
Das musste auch vom Handschirur operiert werden.
Ich glaube, das heißt Kahnbein.
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Vor drei Jahren?
Ja.
Vor drei Jahren haben Sie eine rechte Hand.
An der linken Hand.
Da ist ein Handwurzelknochen gebrochen.
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Er wurde erst gegipst und dann war das nicht richtig und dann musste es operiert werden.
Das war das Kahnbein.
Okay, einverstanden.
Und der erste Bruch war vor?
Wie viele Jahren vor war das?
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Und das war Anfang des Jahres?
War das weiter?
Nein, war nur einmal.
Nur einmal, okay.
Er war gebrochen, aber dann wurde es erst mit einem Gips behandelt.
Das war ein Gips, okay.
Nicht geholfen.
Okay, danke.
Und Herr Pettersen, gibt Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Allergien habe ich nicht.
Und Verträglichkeit?
Nein, ich kann alles vertragen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht oder aufs Land gewesen?
Nein, ich war immer in Deutschland in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Auch während Corona, während Corona und so war ich immer in Deutschland.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, nicht meine Gegend Corona und Kindheit,
Grundimpfungen, haben Sie schon durchgeführt?
Ja, ja, ich habe immer mal wieder auch Arbeitsunfälle gehabt.
Und dann habe ich Verletzungen gehabt an der Haut und dann kriegte ich immer
richtig immer Tetanusimpfung und bin auch gegen Corona viermal geimpft.
Danke schön.
Herr Pettersen, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche ziemlich viel.
Oh, ja.
Ich brauche 20 Zigaretten am Tag und schon ziemlich lange, 35 Jahre.
Und trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, trinke ich auch.
Was trinken Sie wie oft?
Beiflaschen Bier am Tag und so zwei bis drei Schnäpse.
Am Tag, ne?
Seid unterenken Sie so?
Ja, auch schon, seitdem ich berufstätig bin.
Ungefähr 30 kann man sagen, ne?
Ja.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, Herr Pettersen.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, das ist gut.
Na so wie ist Ihre Familie, Herr Pettersen?
Ich bin geschieden.
Ich lebe alleine.
Ja, haben Sie alle?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, 26 und 28 Jahre.
Die haben beide Asthma.
Sind Sie junger oder Mädchen beide?
Beides Mädchen.
Okay.
Was machen Sie auf beruflich?
Ich bin im Straßenbau.
Straßenbauer.
Sind Sie früh mit Ihrem Beruf, mit Ihrem Job?
Ja, bin schon früh.
Es ist sehr anstrengend.
Bei Wind und Wetter, bei Kälte, bei Hitze.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Pettersen, ich möchte über Ihre Eltern etwas wissen.
Also, als erblicher Erkrankungen leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen
oder erbliche Erkrankungen?
Der Vater ist mit 60 Jahren verstorben an Magenkrebs.
Tut mir leid, ja?
Ja.
Und die Mutter, die ist 80 Jahre alt, lebt.
Und die hat Alterszucker.
Und hatte vor 20 Jahren, glaube ich, eine Geilenblasen-Operation wegen Geilensteinen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist 52 Jahre alt.
Bei der ist vor einem Jahr Brustkrebs festgestellt worden.
Und der hat Chemotherapie bekommen und ist operiert worden.
Und im Augenblick sieht das ganz gut aus.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Pettersen.
Ich habe in meiner Seite alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Ich möchte kurz über das Zusammenfassend machen und so sicher gehen.
Ja.
Sie haben seit zehn Stunden starken, heftiger Bauchschmerzen.
Die Bauchschmerzen sind ein Ganzbauchbereich, mehr Oberbereich.
Bei Bewegung wird er verschlimmert sich.
Und die Chemerzen, dumfer und weller Formig.
Die Chemerzen sind acht oder neun Stake.
Sie haben so eingesetzen.
Und sie haben schon innerhalb zweijahren dreimal ähnliche Beschwerden erlebt.
Aber dieses Mal, die letzte Mal, sie bekommen mehr Chemerzen als andere.
Ja.
Und sie haben dagegen zweimal Arresttomoffe eingenommen.
Ich denke 500 Milligramm.
Aber dass sie ihnen nicht geholfen, die Chemerzen strahlen in Rücken.
Also sie haben keine Fieber, aber sie leiden unter nach Schweiß.
Sie haben dreimal erbrochen, also innerhalb zehn Stunden, meinen Sie, ne?
Ja, so innerhalb der Zeit, die die Schmerzen so stark sind.
Und sie haben auch Urbel, Appetitlosigkeit.
Und sie haben innerhalb zweijahren acht Kilo verloren.
Und sie haben nicht versucht, diese Kilo abgenommen gerade.
Nein, nicht bewusst.
Okay.
Und so vor einem Tag, warum das gar nicht gut lesen kann,
vor einem Tag, was haben wir gespülen können, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich hatte Stuhlgang vor einem Tag.
Ja, so, ja.
Ich habe noch etwas vergessen.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit, an beiden Unterschenkeln spüre ich so ein Kribbeln und Brennen.
Auch unter der Fußsäule, das ist so manchmal so pelziges Gefühl.
Und ich habe in den letzten fünf Jahren dreimal eine Magenspiegelung gehabt,
wegen zwölf Fingerdammgeschwür.
Okay.
Sie haben das ganz gut mir gesagt, ja, Sie haben ganz gut gemacht.
Also ich habe das vergessen, so fragen, dass Sie Magenspiegel und Drückstüffel.
Noch eine Frage, Herr Petersen.
Vor zehn Stunden haben Sie eine Stimmersmittel eingenommen, zum Beispiel über die Klo von Jakob.
Nur Paracetamol.
Sie haben nur Paracetamol.
Dr. Ali, Deine Seite ist vorbei.
Ja, 20 Minuten.
Okay.
Aber ich denke, wir haben alle Stücke schon erledigt.
Nein, haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen, sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plöstisch angefangen?
Die haben langsam angefangen.
Waren Ihre Einzige beschwerden in Bezug auf die Darberhäufigkeit Schmerzinterste?
Innerhalb, zwei Jahren, dreimal, ja.
Ja, dreimal, aber ...
War nicht so stark, nicht ganz so stark.
Wie viel Stunden dauert?
Das hat so zwei, drei Tage gedauert.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bemerk, haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpern?
Ja, bevor ich den Herzkatheter hatte, da habe ich ja ...
Jetzt momentan, seit den Schäden, die Übelkeit, die Erbüchern und andere.
Ja, und starke Bauchschmerzen.
Starke Bauchschmerzen, okay.
Was Schlimmste sind die Bauchschmerzen?
Das ist das Stärkste.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bemerk, dass Ihr Haut oder Augen in der Säzeit gelten, ist geworden?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn Ihrer Bauchschmerzen gehen, wie Tag?
Ja, ja.
Wie sieht Ihre Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen wenig, weil ich glaube, ich habe wenig getrunken in den letzten Stunden und ich habe so stark geschwitzt.
Der Urin war heute Morgen ganz dunkel.
Ganz dunkel, okay.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ich habe Stuhlgang vor 25 Stunden.
Wie sieht das aus?
Beschreiben Sie bitte, können Sie beschreiben?
Ich habe diesen Stuhlgang nicht angeguckt, weil es mir ja doch ganz gut ging.
Da hatte ich ja noch diese Schmerzen.
Aber mit Stuhlgang hatte ich bisher eigentlich nie Probleme gehabt.
Das war eigentlich immer in Ordnung.
Vielleicht, ich will Schmerzen, eigentlich her und vorher und jetzt momentan.
Nach dem Essen auf die Tritten sind?
Nein, manche Leute sagen ja, wenn ich jetzt etwas besonderes esse, dann bekomme ich Beschwerden oder Vertrage.
Das war bei mir bisher nie der Fall.
Ich kann das nicht sagen, dass es mit dem Essen zu tun hat.
Haben Sie so brennen, sores Aufstoßen oder Beleihungen?
Manchmal, aber das ist viel besser geworden.
Ich habe Medikamente bekommen wegen der 12-Fingerdamm-Geschwüre vor einigen Jahren.
Das ist dann noch mal kontrolliert worden, aber zurzeit nehme ich keine Magen-Tabletten ein.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Diese Fragen schon gefragt, Dr. Wischer.
Ist Ihnen nun momentan Alkoholkonsum gefragt?
Blut im Erbrochen nicht gefragt?
Wie sieht Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Das war mehr so gelblich, schleimig, aber Blut war da glaube ich nicht bei.
Diese Frage habt ihr gestartet, wie ernähren Sie sich ausreichend oder wenig?
Sie haben gesagt, sind Sie schmerzlos vom Ausgangsort gefragt?
Sie haben Antwort.
Die meisten Sperzen sind oben im Oberbauch und auch so ein bisschen im Rücken.
Aber der gesamte Bauch tut weh, aber am meisten ist es im Oberbauch.
Können wir als Staatsgeschichte anfangen, Alerbe?
Ja, bitte.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberbaus. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin auch genommen.
Ich würde gerne diese Patientin Ihnen vorstellen.
Danke schön.
Es geht um Frank Pettersen.
Er sei 53 Jahre alt, wurde vierteverbraunen, 1970 Gebrochen.
Er sei 73 Kilogramm und 1,84 Kilogramm schwer.
1,84 Kilogramm groß und 73 Kilogramm schwer.
Ich habe etwas umgekehrt.
Ein bisschen, Entschuldigung.
Er sei 73 Kilogramm schwer und 1,84 Kilogramm groß.
Der Patient stört sich heute Morgen bei uns auf Grund seit 10 Stunden bestehende,
dumfer, krampfartig, langsam auch trätende Abdominalgie.
Der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerz- meistern Oberbauch erfrächtlich sein würde.
Er wurde auf der Schmerzskala bei 9 Einzelordnern seit.
8 bis 9, ja.
Er hatte Schmerzen aus.
Entschuldigung.
Schmerzen würde in den Rücken ausstrahlen.
Ich habe den Patienten zweimal in den Rücken eingenommen,
der ihnen teilweise nicht geholfen.
Ohne wesentliche Wirkung, ja.
Der Patient erwähnt, dass er innerhalb 2-3 Jahre ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt habe.
Aber er lässt das mal sehr starken geworden.
Die vegetative Anamese ist unaufwillig bis auf Nachschweiß.
Er ist 3-mal imesisch und neuser.
Aber ich habe vergessen, dass er die erbrochenen Konsistenz und Farbe und die Ausstatt des Freien verabredet hat.
Nachschweiß oder Schwitzen?
Ich denke Schwitzen.
Ja, es war besonders Nachtschweiß.
Hyperheterosis oder Nachtschweiß?
Das Erbrechen war gelblich, schleimig.
Die Farbe ist gelblich und Konsistenz schleimig.
Außer der Patient unter Inappetanz und Besüglich.
Sie haben innerhalb 2 Jahre von ca. 8 kg Gewicht Lust abgenommen.
An der letzten Stuhlgang?
Das war vor einem Tag.
Es ist normal.
Der Patient klagt über Beide, Hypostesie und Parästhesie.
Er wurde vor einem Jahr eine Ulkustöedonid festgestellt.
Vor einem Jahr?
Vor 2 Jahren.
Das habe ich nicht gemotiert, aber erinnere mich, es war 2 Jahren sein.
Er berichtet über dreibahlige Gastroskopie.
Innerhalb der letzten Jahre wegen Ulzara duodeni.
Er ist aus der Risikokonstellation des Patienten?
Er ist Raucher und trinke Alkohol.
Er konsumiert Alkohol.
Er hat lange Zeit erleden mit dem Rhythmie.
Er wurde vor einem Jahr eine Rangio und diese erritten mit der Kante betreffend behandelt.
Vor einem Jahr erfolgt er eine Krüo-Aplation.
Er wegelt wohl absoluter Arhythmie.
Seitdem ist der Patient diesbezüglich beschwerdefrei.
Er besteht ein erheblicher Nikotinabusus über 35 Packages.
Ein auffälliger erhöhter erheblicher Alkoholkonsum.
Er ist seit 5 Jahren ein Hyperton.
Er beträgt die Hyperton-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H.
Er hat 20 Milligramm im Abend täglich.
Der Patient wurde mit 10 rechthaltiger Ingrinal-Herr-Operationen durchgeführt.
Vor 3 Jahren wurde der Anfragter mit dem Gips behandelt.
Er hat nicht gut behandelt mit dem Gips.
Nachher wurde eine operative Behandlung durchgeführt.
Er erfolgt die operative Versorgung einer Navigulare-Fraktur.
Kann man das?
Navigulare-Fraktur wurde operativ versorgt.
Das ist eine Beinfragter oder Alenfragter?
Ein Kapfolizat.
Es gibt Aufhelligkeiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Sein Vater ist mit 60 verstorben aufgrund Magenkarsnum.
Er ist 80 Jahre alt und leidet Diabetes-Me-Lytisch.
Vor 20 Jahren wurde er in eine Polystethyndrisch geführt.
Er ist 52 Jahre alt und war vor einem jahren ein Magenkarsnum.
Er hat Schema um operativ versorgt.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Analystischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Urkustdörde-Pepforation.
Die Diagnose ist von Morphis-Prom, Gastritis, Pankratitis, Pankreiskarsinom, Colitis-Ditis oder Colitis.
Der Patient hat die Vorgeschichte von Ulzeraduodini.
Er hat eine erhebliche Risikokonzentration bezüglich Nikotinabusus und Alkoholabusus.
Vor dem Hintergrund hat er den akuten Schub einer chronisch rezidivierenden Pankratitis.
Seit zwei Jahren hat er schon dreimal auch Schmerzen.
Er hat erhebliche Erkrankungsrisiko bezüglich Alkoholkonsums.
Er hat inzwischen eine Polyneuropathie entwickelt.
Er hat eine Erkrankungsdörde, die sich um einen akuten Schub einer chronischen Pankratitis handelt.
Er hat seit zwei Jahren von 8 kg.
Er hat eine positive Ulkustdörde-Pepforation.
Ich glaube, in diesen beiden Bereichen wird es sich abspielen.
Ja, ich denke, Sie haben das systematisch erfasst.
Sie haben vergessen zu fragen, ob Sie sonst Erkrankungen haben.
Sie haben gefragt nach chronischen Krankheiten, aber dann haben Sie das verlassen.
Ich habe dreimal eine Magenspiegelung gehabt.
Ich versuche, das systematisch zu erfassen, weil dann können Sie das Bild besser einschätzen.
Auch bei dem ersten Satz, der Patient war sehr kompliziert.
Herr Petersen ist ein 53-Jähriger Patient, der sich akut vorstellt wegen akuter Abdominalarbeschwerden.
Sie haben seit zehn Stunden gestehen.
Dann können Sie den nächsten Satz machen.
Es ist nicht so viel Stress, einen deutschen Satz zu konstruieren.
Das ist manchmal schwierig.
Das sage ich immer wieder, aber ich fülle mir jetzt auch wieder auf, dass wir das vielleicht beachten.
Wenn Sie diese Alamnese erheben, bitte nicht zu oft auf den Zettel schauen,
sondern immer wieder den Patienten anschauen, mal einen Blickkontakt oder den Oberarzt anschauen.
Ich weiß aber, es ist schwierig. Ich kann mir vorstellen, wie schwierig das ist.
Schwierster Teil ist, welche Sache müssen Sie konzentrieren?
Einmal Deutsch oder die Klinik?
Die Fachbegriffe.
Ich habe extra das schwierige Wort die Tüde H.
Es ist, glaube ich, Hydrochlorotheazit und Trianperin, wenn ich wichtig.
Ja, Triantin und Hydrochlorotheazit.
Deswegen auch mal ein etwas schwierigeres Mittel.
Wenn Sie das eben sagen können, Sie können das bitte Buch stabilieren.
Genau richtig.
Aufschreiben.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Ich werde diese Prüfung am Ende.
27.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen dafür viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank.